LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi, and
welcome to this series
on Geocasts, where you can
walk your way through what
you can do with Google Maps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In Part 1, we saw how you
can delegate your mapping
work to the Google Maps app.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
And in the second
part of the series,
I'm going to talk about how you
can go further and incorporate
Google Maps functionality
right into your app.
So, for example, say I
just want a simple map.
And I want the minimum
of coding overhead.
Well, how would I do this?
There's lots of options.
The first is to use the
Web Static Maps API.
And this is as
simple as it can be.
You pass the API a URL,
and you get a map back.
Now, there's a lot of variety in
the type of maps you get back.
And here you can see some styled
maps, some satellite images,
and even some routing.
And it's as simple as
passing at URL like this.
Often, a static
map isn't enough.
And you might want to
embed a map on your site.
But you don't want to handle
writing lots of script.
Well, you can use the Embed
API and an iframe in this case.
Here, you can see an embedded
map, including navigation
and traffic conditions.
And here, as you can see,
is my favorite technology
in Google Maps, which is
an embedded Street View.
Now what's more, there
are no quotas for Maps
or other geo information
presented in this way using
the embedded API.
OK, now let's talk addresses.
These are notoriously difficult
to get right when you're
typing on a small device.
With that in mind, there's a
place auto-complete control.
And this supports address auto
complete for web, Android,
and iOS.
It gives you an
editable text field
with accurate suggestions
for addresses and place
names upon each key press.
And this is how
it works in code.
On iOS, you'll launch an
auto-complete controller
and then just capture
the result. On Android,
you'll launch an activity using
the place auto-complete intent
builder.
And then you simply
catch its result.
Now, you might not always
want to type an address
to share your location.
You might just want to
point to it on a map.
And, with that in mind, there's
the PlacePicker control.
And here's the code.
On iOS, you use a GMS
PlacePicker control.
And you get place
details such as the place
name from the callback.
And on Android, you just
start a new activity
that's built from a
PlacePicker intent.
And just cache the data
and the activity results.
And that brings us to
the end of this episode.
Here, we spoke about
how you can incorporate
Google Maps into your app
or site with minimal coding.
But many developers
want deeper integration
and powerful customization.
You'll see that in
the next episode.
[MUSIC PLAYING]